now that we have in our hands the PMF of
the random variable n tau which is the
number of arrivals during an interval of
length tau we can go ahead and try to
calculate the mean and variance of this
quantity regarding the mean we could use
just the definition of the expected
value and then carry out this
calculation which is not too hard and in
the end we would obtain an answer equal
to lambda times tau this is indeed the
correct formula for the expected value
but let us understand why this formula
should be true without doing any
calculation remember that the random
variable the number of arrivals in the
Poisson process is well approximated by
a binomial random variable with those
particular parameters N and P in the
limit when Delta goes to 0 and this was
through a discretization argument
therefore the expected value of n tau
should be approximately equal to the
expected value that we get from the
Bernoulli process that means the
expected value of a binomial random
variable and the expected value of a
binomial random variable is n times P
and n times P evaluates approximately to
lambda times tau this second equality
here is approximate because we're
neglecting this order of Delta squared
term now these approximations are
increasingly exact as we let Delta go to
0 and when we take the limit as Delta go
to 0 we see that the expected value of a
number of arrivals in the Poisson
process will be equal to lambda tau for
the variance we can follow a similar
argument first do binomial approximation
and use the formula for the variance of
a binomial random variable and then when
Delta is small this number P is small
and it's negligible compared to 1 n
times P is approximately lambda T and so
we obtain this expression
this expression here is the correct one
if we were to use the formal definition
of the variance and carry out the
calculations using the PMF this is what
we would obtain except that it could be
somewhat tedious the formula that we
have derived at least the first one is
quite intuitive and has a natural form
the expected number of arrivals is
proportional to tau if we double the
length of the time interval of interest
we expect to see twice as many arrivals
this formula also reinforces the
interpretation of lambda as an arrival
rate since lambda is the expected number
of arrivals divided by the length of
time it is really the expected number of
arrivals per unit time so it is natural
to call lambda the arrival rate or the
intensity of the arrival process finally
regarding the variance it is a curious
fact that the variance turns out to be
exactly the same as the expected value
and this is a special property of the
Poisson PMF